in der abwägung all diese schicksale
bedürfnisse und rechte sind die kinder
bisher sie haben darauf aufmerksam
gemacht im grunde unter den tisch
gefallen warum
ja das frage ich mich auch also ich
freue mich dass wir uns heute hier mehr
treffen ich muss sagen dass die
tatsächlich mir jetzt erst in dieser
woche mit setzen aufgefallen sind die
dann auch die kinder mal mit rein
gebracht haben ins verhältnis gebracht
haben wir haben lange über sport
diskutiert ja was alles ausfällt
olympias verschoben ja und die kinder
müssen abitur machen
also ich glaube tatsächlich dass
familien oder das was mir begegnet ist
gar nicht so dieses mein kind hat ein
recht auf bildung was ist mit dem abitur
was ist mit der weit es ist ja sozusagen
ohren auf das komplette leben ist ja
jetzt sozusagen dieses schuljahr dass
wir verlieren ja alle ein bisschen zeit
ja ich glaube schon dass die familien an
so einem punkt sind wo sie sagen wir
machen uns das leben so gut wie es geht
und wir machen das beste draus das
problem ist aber dass ebendieses wir
machen das beste draus nicht
funktioniert weil wenn ich arbeiten muss
wie soll ich arbeiten wenn ich ein kind
betreuen muss es geht auch nicht nur um
diese extremfälle ja ich meine wir
müssen auch ehrlich sein
kinder die jetzt nicht gut zu hause
aufgehoben sind sie sind auch ansonsten
nicht so wahnsinnig gut zu hause
aufgehoben ja also es gibt keine neuen
probleme eigentlich sondern es gibt sehr
viele probleme die schon sonst auch da
sind die aber jetzt eben ungefiltert auf
dem tisch liegen und schon fragen wir
die familienministerin vgh wäre es nicht
ihre aufgabe gewesen
mit der ersten diskussion der
ministerpräsidenten darauf aufmerksam zu
machen was das eigentlich für die kinder
bedeutet also ich will mal ganz klar
sagen das thema kinder und familien und
die situation von kindern und familien
die war von anfang an einer meiner ganz
großen schwerpunkte und das haben wir
auch in die debatte eingebracht aber wir
müssen schon teilen wie war die
diskussion wir haben am anfang der
erstmals auch zum beispiel so was für
den notfall kinderzuschlag gemacht um
familien die massiven einkommenseinbruch
haben auch finanziell zu helfen
dazu gehören auch sagen wir
kurzarbeitergeld usw aber wie klingt da
nun aber erstmal hat unmittelbar
natürlich man muss jetzt natürlich die
situation sehen wir sind jetzt in der
sechsten woche dabei noch zwei wochen
osterferien dabei es kommt jetzt in
einer lage wo wirklich auf familien das
zunehmend als belastung
finden und wo wir natürlich auch fragen
stellen müssen wie kindeswohlgefährdung
kinderschutz und so weiter wir haben ja
deshalb auch mit den jugend und familien
wenn es dann uns darauf verständigt in
den ländern das eben es bestimmte
gruppen gibt die jetzt besondere
hilfestellung brauchen und auch in die
erweiterte notbetreuung aufgenommen
werden was auch schon geschieht gerade
auch bei den fällen wo das jugendamt zum
beispiel sagt das ist eine
problematische situation dieses kind ist
besser in eine öffentlichen
kinderbetreuung auch aufgehoben oder
sollte das zusätzlich bekommen kinder
mit sprachförderbedarf kinder die eine
besondere entwicklungsauffälligkeiten
und zusätzliche förderung benötigen dass
die im mit aufgenommen werden auch
kinder von erwerbstätigen
alleinerziehend sind in einer
schwierigen situation diese notbetreuung
wird ja jetzt erweitert nicht nur auf
die systemrelevanten berufe sondern auch
auf die gruppen darin kinder die schule
eben in einer besonders schwierigen lage
ich möchte noch mal sagen das ist wir
sind jetzt sechs wochen im lag lockdown
ja ja das ist eigentlich so etwas
abstand wirklich mit alleinerziehenden
zu tun die sagen ich muss home office
machen und ich muss gegen ein kind
betreuen ein kleinkind und ein schulkind
und ich habe noch riesendruck von der
schule weil ich noch homeschooling ist
das ja auch sondern hohen learning also
lehrer sozusagen sind jetzt an zu hause
die eltern ja und das da frage ich mich
halt wirklich und ich meine sie sagen es
gibt auch finanzielle unterstützung das
kommt bei den familien nicht an das kann
ich ihnen sagen die würden viele würden
mit ihrem arbeitgeber gerne vereinbaren
dass sich ein bisschen zurück zieht und
um die kinder kümmert weil das das
problem der familien ist die
gleichzeitigkeit ja ist sie gleich zeit
man kann nicht alles gleichzeitig man es
funktioniert also ich sehe dass ein dass
das ich habe erstmal vollstes
verständnis für die situation in den
familien wir haben ja auch zum beispiel
entschädigungsleistung nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz die laufen wenn
die eltern ihre kinder eben nicht in die
betreuung geben können jetzt wir haben
natürlich diese schwierigkeit mit der
gleichzeitigkeit mit homeschooling usw
und dann muss es auch deswegen plädiere
dafür dass wir eben sagen wir können das
nicht auf lange sicht jetzt einfach so
weiterlaufen lassen also eine
perspektive bis zum sommer das geht
nicht und deshalb ist ja auch mit den
jugend und familienminister vereinbart
wurden schrittweise nur betreuung
deutlich erweitern auf die bedarfs-
gruppen denen es jetzt besonders schwer
wieder los die notbetreuung dahin hier
auch so wichtig dass es wirklich
auflagen der herbst werden kann ich
viele familien erlebt die das versucht
haben und wo das nicht funktioniert
haben hat weil eben die kinder die
menschen nicht kennen weil alle mit
schutzmasken rumlaufen die eltern
durften nicht mit in die räume reingehen
kinder sind keine kleinen kätzchen die
man irgendwo abgibt sind das ganze ja
auch auf das ist ja genau der punkt der
jetzt auch schwierig ist eben wenn man
über hygienestandards rede kleinere
gruppen andere betreuungszeiten sind das
genau die praktischen und
organisatorischen probleme aber es ist
auch klar wir können nicht von heute auf
morgen alles wieder öffnen sondern es
gibt einigkeit darüber dass das nur
stufenweise gehen kann ich finde wichtig
die perspektive auf die nächste woche
auf den 6 wo ja die ministerpräsident
sich heute auch verständigt haben das
erlebe ich es sogar ebenso zeitlichen
börse wurde die haben satz zu sagen
sie konnten sie dürfen jedoch nicht sie
müssen einen brauchen unbedingt noch mal
mit china sieht jetzt haben wir eine
neue studie auf dem tisch von christian
drosten charité biologie ihr kollege der
hat herausgefunden dass kinder genauso
infektiös wie erwachsene sind also
eigentlich bestätigung dieser island
studie 15 prozent die studie ist noch
nicht geprüft wie sehen sie macht wie
sehen sie diese studie machen wir
gegebenenfalls zu früh auf weil eben
doch kinder auch ein infektionsrisiko
haben und damit die eltern und die
erwachsenen das kann man ja so als
designstudie nicht ableiten erstmal ist
es ganz wichtig dass solche studien
stattfinden sie wären jetzt auch
vermehrt in deutschland durchgeführt um
genau eben erkenntnisse zu gewinnen
inwieweit eben öffnung möglich sind und
welche gefahr davon ausgehen kann
die studie die christen durchgefüttert
oder vielmehr natürlich die kollegen die
mit christian arbeiten das ist ein
großes institut
die kommen auch viel zu selten sozusagen
dadurch in den vordergrund die haben
geschaut so zu sagen ob die virus menge
die sich im rachen nachweisen lässt
ähnlich hoch ist wie bei erwachsenen
und das konnte nachgewiesen werden in
einer begrenzten anzahl von kindern das
heißt aber natürlich noch nicht welche
oder man kann dadurch nicht ich sage
beantworten so zu sagen welches
infektionsrisiko in hama gärten vor
nicht kranken oder nicht erkrankten
kindern auch ausgeht also da sind
weitere studien notwendig wir haben
andere studien aus china sie haben auch
andere studien aus holland und eben aus
island angesprochen wo es so aussieht
als ob kinder er immer sozusagen der
endpunkt einer infektionskette sind und
eben nicht der ausgang führen
was hier für die entscheidung hilfreich
wäre ihm weitere öffnungen zuzulassen
ansonsten muss ich auch nochmal sagen
dass ich als die runden nur wie immer
gesagt habe wir müssen jenseits von
corona gucken was für schäden
angerichtet werden durch den
wirtschaftlichen schaden in
medizinischer hinsicht und wir sehen
auch aufgrund der datenlage der
krankenkassen dak zum beispiel dass wir
weniger herzinfarkte haben also dass die
leute weniger ins krankenhaus gehen und
sich auch behandeln das also große
probleme damit verbunden und er gibt ja
jetzt auch die entscheidung zu öffnen
und wieder zuzulassen dass das ist ganz
wichtig könnte so und jetzt trotzdem
noch mal zu denen dann haben wir diesen
bezug noch mal hergestellt sehr gut
jetzt trotzdem noch mal zu den lehrern
und den erziehern die setzen wir herr
schmidt chanasit einem ähnlichen risiko
aus wie die pflegerinnen und pfleger ist
es also richtig dass wir bei den lehrern
sagen die kollegen die über 60 sind
gehen besser nicht in die schulen oder
in die also da muss man das kann man so
pauschal nicht sagen da muss man sich
ganz genau die situation angucken wir
müssen schauen über welche altersgruppen
geräten es wird unterschiede geben bei
den unter zehnjährigen und eben die
älter sind wir können bei den älteren
letztendlich auch er darauf einwirken
bestimmte abstands sozusagen gebote und
masken letztendlich zu benutzen und dann
muss man durch auch auf lehrerseite
schon wie man dort auch schützen kann
durch entsprechende maßnahmen natürlich
die kollegen mit sehr vielen
vorerkrankungen die eben sehr gefährdet
wären da muss man sich dann eben
überlegen ob die wirklich dennoch eben
zur arbeit zurückkehren können oder wie
man die ihn schützen kann das muss da
natürlich in den konzepten auch eine
wichtige rolle ich auch da würden test
natürlich helfen wenn man an schulen das
hatte eher lindner gesagt eine
begleitende forschung auch weiter
passieren würde ganz auch eine studie
mit dem robert koch institut und dem
deutschen jugendinstitut in auftrag
geben die genau diese fragen bewertet
jetzt wo alle kinder zu hause sind kann
man nicht so viel sehen aber was ist
denn jetzt die notbetreuung ausgeweitet
wird das muss auch wissenschaftlich
begleitet werden was passiert denn
eigentlich mit dem infektionsgeschehen
und dann muss das bewertet also diese
erkenntnisse darüber halte ich für sehr
wichtig deshalb werden wir da auch und
haben sie die sorge wenn sie die zahlen
von christian drosten lesen dass wir
gegebenenfalls zu früh auf machen
mit welchem gefühl sind sie
jetzt eine die dafür plädiert dass wir
endlich schulen und kitas
beides sind die risiken und
nebenwirkungen die frau saalfrank sie
beschreibt wir sehen die die belastungen
die das für kinder bedeutet für das
kindeswohl bedeutet wir müssen das
abwägen und kinderschutz ist auch
gesundheitsschutz und deswegen müssen
wir da können wir nicht kategorisch
seien ja oder nein sondern deswegen ist
es ja richtig immer dürfen vorzugehen
und genau das wollen wir auch machen
also ich halte mich an einer
biologischen studie der hinweis ist
wirklich ganz aktuell wichtig nicht an
einer studie fest machen denn wenn man
den medien von heute abend glauben kann
hat er trotzdem gestern gesagt kinder
sind so infektiös wie erwachsene und
heute sagt denn nur ein drittel so
gefährlich wie unlängst berichtet worden
ist also zwei gegenteiliger aussagen
innerhalb von 24 stunden wenn das
richtig berichtet wird hat die kanzlerin
das ja heute in der konferenz mit den
ministerpräsidenten ausdrücklich
kritisiert man würde sich wünschen dass
die virologen und epidemiologen einmal
wie die kardinäle zur papstwahl in einem
konklave zusammen kommen und wenn sie
sich einig sind steigt weißer rauch auf
das verrückte ist der lindner dass sie
jeden tag schlauer werden und dass wir
dieses schlauer werden und mehr wissen
mit ihnen teilen
hier sind jetzt beide nicht ihre lockt
auch auch total wissenschafts freundlich
und freue mich über jede neue erkenntnis
aber wenn man an einem tag sagt genauso
gefährlich wie erwachsen und am nächsten
tag heißt es nur ein drittel
dann ist das ein sehr schneller
erkenntnisse sind es 15 prozent die navi
erwachsene haben sie ein 15 prozentiges
infektionsrisiko ungefähr ist so ist
dass herr schmidt chanasit frau immer
gerade heute wird was anderes in den
medien bringt zwei gegenläufige zitate
ich habe jetzt gar nicht mein punkt kann
man ja schauen ich glaube die bild
zeitung hat das berichtet hier geht es
um den anderen punkt nämlich um die
frage der öffnung aber hier kommt erst
mal meine frage dazu also wir haben
tatsächlich eine notbetreuung
eingerichtet dagegen es darum dass vor
allen dingen die die in besonders
wichtigen berufen arbeiten wieder zur
arbeit können noch mal die frage haben
wir die kinder unter den tisch fallen
lassen und ging es auch da eigentlich
eher darum dass mutter und vater wieder
zur arbeit können und weniger um die
kinder
also zunächst natürlich sagen nein wir
haben wir waren in einer ausnahme nie
wirklich nicht sage ich jetzt gleich
auch wir waren als staatliche
verantwortungsgemeinschaft in einer
ausnahmesituation
und natürlich wird dann alles getan um
einer unbekannten gefahr zu begegnen und
dann werden auch kitas und schulen
geschlossen sowie auch hotels und lokale
und läden und so weiter nun jetzt ist
doch die frage wie kommen wir raus und
wir müssen raus pause als kinder wir
müssen ja die kinder müssen raus die
wollen gleichaltrige sehen das sind
entwicklungschancen die verloren gehen
und insbesondere diejenigen die ohnehin
schon in einer benachteiligung situation
sind erwarte ich mir gar nicht ausdenken
was da in mancher kleinen wohnung ohne
balkon passiert also insofern die müssen
raus und jetzt ist die frage wie und da
bin ich einigermaßen doch erstaunt wie
die aktuelle politische entwicklung
lässt die jugend und familienminister
haben ein modell das geht zurück auf
initiativen meines nachfolgers in
nordrhein westfalen dem familienminister
joachim stammt von der fdp zusammen mit
seiner spd kollegin aus hamburg machen
die ein gemeinsames konzept wir haben da
sein er auch mit gabel astrotv de fauw
begrüßt hat das liegt vor frau merkel
sagt beschließen wir diese woche nicht
schauen wir nächste woche eine woche
verloren gegangen für vorbereitung
dasselbe passiert in der
kultusministerkonferenz die 16
schulminister der länder entwickeln ein
konzept unter welchen bedingungen können
schulen öffnen
speziell in nordrhein westfalen gibt es
jetzt eine einigkeit der regierung der
kommunen die als schulträger
verantwortlich sind zum beispiel für
desinfektionsmittel und der
gewerkschaften also der beschäftigten
der lehrer erzieher frau merkel sorgt
hier sprechen diese woche nicht erst
einmal jo heute in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit selber
mit dabei es wurde sehr sehr viel
darüber gesprochen wo ist das wurde auch
genauso darüber gesprochen dass eben das
infektionsgeschehen in den bundesländern
sehr unterschiedlich ist hier ja auch
unterschiedlich vorgehen und das ist
genau der punkt und das muss geklärt
werden aber die leute wollen auch ein
bundeseinheitliches abgestimmtes
vorgehen das muss man doch sagen
dass die kinder eben nicht
unterschiedlich behandelt werden und der
rahmen der beschlossen wurde von den
kultusministern aber auch von den
jugendverbänden ist dann der bietet ja
auch jetzt schon die möglichkeiten mehr
zu tun und das was sie einfordern
die bedarfsgerechte und auch kindes
orientierte betreuungs ausweitung die
passiert schon also kinder die in einer
schweren lage sind werden ja auch
zusätzlich aufgenommen wir sprechen über
die forschungen sind auch als große
schwerpunkt gruppe dort mit einbezogen
worden und das wird nächste woche ja
dann auch geeint werden nur es muss
natürlich auch eine entscheidung über
die zeitpunkt gegeben werden das haben
die familienminister und die
kultusminister noch nicht gemacht und
das ist die aufgabe für die nächsten
zwei arbeitstage bis zum nächsten jahr
aber dann will ich dann da modifiziere
ich mein vorwurf wenn das noch nicht
passiert ist dann halte ich das für
einen echten mangel denn wenn wir in den
nächsten wochen kitas und schulen ist ja
sehr voraussetzung für eine schule zu
schließen geht leicht hochzufahren ganz
schwer
allein in nordrhein westfalen sind
schätze mal 30 prozent der lehrkräfte
die gar nicht zur verfügung stehen nur
stufenweise das ist ja alles so formell
das ist nicht mehr präsent und sie
müssen auch das in ferien wir aufgeben
wollen das ist nicht der dissens das ist
ja alles schon in den konzepten von
kultusministern und jugendminister
enthalten das sind ja 16 hochkompetente
landesverwaltungen die die lage vor ort
kennenlernen meint vor aufrichtet ja
nicht sich an sie richtet sich auch
nicht an die kultus und analysieren die
bundesländer kritisierten nicht
notwendig ist was das wieder eine woche
ins land gegangen ist und ich bin
weiteren punkt wenn sie gestatten noch
kurze noch einen in ergänzung zur frau
gefallen ich bin kein anhänger mehr
eines bundeseinheitlichen vorgehens
warum wir haben regional völlig
unterschiedliches infektionsgeschehen
und es gibt zwei landkreise in bayern da
ist noch viel los da würde ich sagen
kann keine schule geöffnet werden keine
kita kein geschäft kein login der in
dormagen musste ich jetzt gerade wieder
eine schule schließen weil es da eine
infektion das so ist wenn es nur eine
ist wäre es ein wirklich schöner umstand
wenn es 100 sind können wir den neustart
der schulen gegebenenfalls nicht
wirklich als einen neustart schreiben
wir wissen es noch nicht ob es
vielleicht 100 schulen plötzlich neue in
aktionen gibt das kann niemand mit klar
sagen aber ihr argument wurde darauf
hinauslaufen dass bis zu ein impfstoff
überhaupt gar nichts läuft
und das kann nicht sein und ich spreche
mich dafür aus waren dass wir regional
differenziert vorgehen und wenn es ein
starkes infektionsgeschehen gibt starkes
infektionsgeschehen heißt bezogen auf
100000 einwohner in einer woche mehr als
100 neue infektionen dass er hält schon
als alarmstufe rot wenn es das gibt dann
bin ich absolut dafür regionale den
locker und bei zu waren okay aber in
einer gemeinde gar keinen aktiven fall
mehr geht da können wir uns mehr
zutrauen dann ist es doch an dieser
stelle sehr gut wenn wir liebe zuschauer
mal einen praktiker fragen das soll man
manchmal im leben tun und in dieser
sendung sogar häufiger tun
bei uns ist einer und jetzt kommt's ja
irgendwie auch gleich an die richtige
position
ein lehrer aus berlin und zwar robert
giese er leitet eine gemeinschaftsschule
herr gysi in berlin britz mit insgesamt
1200 schülern jetzt habe ich sie ein
bisschen überfallen
können sie uns beschreiben ist das
mittlerweile an so gut durch
programmierte durchgeplante alltag den
sie erleben wie organisieren sie die
öffnungen an ihrer schule 4200 noch
nicht wieder in betrieb sein denn
schüler ist eine interessante frage also
wir sind mitten im prozess
unsere kollegen arbeiten in teams
entsprechend sich entsprechend ab und
dann werden wir die nächsten schritte
gehen ich würde sagen zu dem was bisher
passiert ist
bisher ist ja interessanterweise
folgendes gemacht worden hier in berlin
zu - von der senatsverwaltung
es sind vor allem abschlussbezogene
jahrgänge wieder in die schule geholt
worden und als nächstes werden die
auslese jahr gegen nicht mal genommen
also die sechste klasse die
vorbereiteten berlin aufs gymnasium auf
die anderen schulform dann die fünfte
klasse
wir sind da ein bisschen unglücklich
darüber weil wir uns gewünscht hätten
dass man uns als schulen mehr vertrauen
entgegen bringt und uns die entscheidung
über das wie man das hier ist ganz viel
davon gesprochen worden dass es sozial
benachteiligte kinder gibt wir wissen
von schulen wo bis zu 20 prozent der
kinder nicht erreicht werden von den
lehrern wo es überhaupt keinen kontakt
gibt wo wir nicht wissen was
auf der anderen seite gibt es auch
schule in berlin die haben überhaupt
kein solches kind es gibt gymnasien da
hat jedes kind ein laptop da hat jedes
kind die betreuung
insofern halte ich die entscheidung über
alle schulformen über alle schulen
hinweg einfach festlegen zu treffen für
frösche nicht richtig und welche
erfahrungen haben sie jetzt mit ihrer
öffnung gemacht wie es bei den großen
wahrscheinlich einfacher ja natürlich
also wir haben in den verschiedenen
verbänden gab es ja so dass diskussionen
soll man die prüfung durchführen soll
man sie nicht durchführen und so ich
persönlich war der meinung ja die
abiturprüfung in berlin sollen
durchgeführt werden weil die schüler hat
ein bisschen schließlich ein unterricht
und die jede schule verfügt über einen
großen raum wenn es die tonlage ist wo
man gemeinsam die prüfung organisieren
kam mit den entsprechenden
abstandsregelung also abiturprüfung ja
wohl alle verbände oder viele verbände
sich dagegen ausgesprochen haben weil
wir noch problematischer fand war der
mittlere schulabschluss weil die im
abitur sind voll gerecht in der regel
also sie sind älter die verstehen worum
es geht um sänger die schüler werden
desto problematischer wird es wir
beobachten dass in der schule sind die
zehnklässler die wir jetzt haben die
jetzt die präsentation springt für die
mitte und schulabschluss machen sind die
ganz diszipliniert war ja auch die
lehrer achten darauf die werden
angesprochen und so weil er die das
infizieren sich die hände
in dem moment wo die die schulen
verlassen sehen wir die sind selten
stückchen weiter weg also wir können
nicht mehr direkt einfluss nehmen da
bilden die rudel und dann kommen sie im
bedürfnis nach miteinander zu reden ich
habe auch oft genug gesehen die umarmen
sich dann und damit konterkarieren die
natürlich die sachen die wir in der
schule organisieren zum teil
ich hab das jetzt in den schüler
elternbrief noch mal geschrieben und wir
bitten alle schüler bestimmte regeln ein
wir haben sieben regeln da mal
formuliert wird abstand zeitungen usw
aber auch wir bitten alle um mundschutz
und haben wir doch gesagt die lehrer die
erwachsenen tieren sozialpädagoge und so
weiter die haben dann selber auch einem
und maske funktioniert das mit den
masken durchwachsen also ich persönlich
fühle ich atme schlechter wenn ich so
ein ding auf habe also mir fällt es
schwer
jetzt muss sich daran gewöhnt er ist
schwierig so und wenn wir jetzt noch mal
nach asien gucken in asien kriegen die
kinder bevor sie die schule betreten am
tor fieber gemessen gibt so eine
möglichkeit was können sie machen die
sind
die hygienischen bedingungen in ihrer
schule das sind zwei fragen also ich sag
mal eins im thermometer ich glaube wir
haben in asien eine andere kultur was
schulen besucht betrifft dass der druck
auf kinder viel höher
ich war während kinder eben auch mit
fieber in die schule geschickt ich
glaube das passiert bei uns also
zumindest deutlich weniger
das behalte ich das wird ein thermometer
jedes kind da abzumessen nicht für nötig
zu den hygieneregeln haben wir natürlich
das problem dass wir im moment also ich
habe im moment noch desinfektionsmittel
für eine woche für eine woche ja ihr
habt heute mit der firma rede tafel für
unser system gibt es nicht erst im
august wieder das heißt wir haben ja nur
lösung mit der firma gefunden also dass
wir der übernächsten woche dann auch
wieder ausreichend bis zum
schuljahresende hoffentlich haben
hygiene ist auch not also diese
desinfektionsmittel sind ja nicht
wirklich notwendig wenn ich die
virologen richtig verstehe
um sich zu schützen eigentlich würde
gründliches händewaschen reichen
das problem ist aber die toiletten sind
begrenzt naja eigentlich darf zur selben
zeit darf eigentlich immer nur ein kind
auf toilette weil es spätestens am
waschbecken können die die abstandsregel
nicht einhalten wenn man sagt 30
sekunden händewaschen kann man
ausrechnen
das hat nicht funktioniert es geht
einfach nicht deswegen brauche ich in
jedem bereich noch eine hand des
infektion und darum kümmern sie sich
ganz nah wie ist doch mit ihrem lehrer
kollegium herr giese also auch da wissen
wir ja schon vor corona das uns lehrer
fehlen
wie viele von ihren stamm lehrern können
sie jetzt überhaupt an den start
schicken also sind also nicht nur lehrer
sind ja auch die erzieherinnen
sozialpädagogen die dann natürlich eine
rolle spielen und natürlich gelesen
wir haben ungefähr 35 prozent die zur
risikogruppe gehören daher gibt eine
verordnung in berlin im muster
hygieneverordnung wo drinsteht sollen
nicht arbeiten und im letzten kapitel
steht dann drin wäre dann aber an den
ausdrücklichen wunsch hat zu arbeiten
sollte schriftlich erklären und aufgrund
des pädagogischen ethos der vorhanden
ist also lehrer wollen ja dass ihre
kinder was lernen gibt es ganz viele
kollegen die dann sagen ich gehöre zwar
zur risikogruppe
aber ich bin trotzdem da also ich kann
jetzt die genaue prozentzahl gar nicht
sagen
wir haben von von der ausstattung her
dass geht er auch in die frage wie wie
kann unterricht eigentlich organisiert
werden haben wir natürlich ein problem
und manchmal auch ein problem mit dem
verordnung die uns erreichen also wir
kriegen weisung aus der schulbehörde wo
dann beispielsweise für die sechste
klasse für nächste woche drin stehen
steht die der unterricht soll nach
stundentafel erfolgen das heißt nach der
normalen stundentafel haben die hätten
die dann ca 28 stunden unterricht das
ist absurd mir so was reinschreiben kann
weil natürlich klar ich habe weniger
lehrer und braucht mindestens doppelt so
viel bräuchte doppelt so viel personal
wir haben aber nur 100 prozent
erstattung viele schulen habe nicht mal
die das heißt wie soll das funktionieren
also ja wir können die stundentafel in
dem sinne wie sie vorgeschrieben ist
nicht auf
hier müssen wir also ein eigenes modell
finden und nun fehlt nicht nur zeit
sondern es fehlt auch platz würden sie
in anbetracht der situation dafür
plädieren herr gysi dass man über
kürzere ferien nachdenkt oder dass man
über den samstag als regulären schultag
wieder nachdenkt um noch mehr kindern
eben nicht nur den einen tag in der
woche zwar wirklich wieder mal zurück
weil ich gesagt habe ich denke man
sollte den vertrauten man sollte in
schulen mehr vertrauen entgegenbringen
also die selbst verantwortete schule
wirklich ernster nehmen weil die
möglichkeit bedingt so lange besteht ja
wir können in berlin per schulkonferenz
beschluss könnten wir sagen wir machen
sondern wieder unterricht ich halte das
aber für keine gute entscheidung weil
die lehrer für das nimmt viele ja nicht
wahr
aber viele lehrer und lehrerinnen
arbeiten viel mehr als jedem regulieren
system arbeiten sie machen den
präsenzunterricht sie machen
homeschooling sie lassen sich das
material in die schule bringen da gibt
es ein system das haben die kollegen
organisiert die holen sich neues
material geben altes material ab das
muss durchgesehen werden neue aufgaben
müssen formuliert werden dass das für
völlig unterschätzt es wird überhaupt
nicht sehen insofern denke ich eine
kürzung der ferien um jetzt weiteren
unterricht mahnte können würde den
kollegen überhaupt nicht gerecht werden
ich denke er an dass da habe ich heute
hört das ist in berlin gibt es eine
planung also eine vorliegen zumindest
dass man auf freiwilliger basis
flächendeckend sommerschulen anbietet wo
beispielsweise die die
nachhilfeinstitute die im moment nicht
arbeiten können mit herangezogen werden
könnten natürlich finanziert werden
müssen so dass kinder die möglichkeit
haben freiwillig diese sommer schulen zu
besuchen
das kann ich mir gut vorstellen wobei es
immer wieder an der frage ist wie man es
mit den abstandsregel wie halten wir
also die allgemeinen regeln ein
diese danke dass sie heute bei uns in
vielen dank für den blick in die praxis
und damit sind wir bei der frage frau
gefallen sollten wir müssten wir dann
nicht tatsächlich argument von herrn
lindner tatsächlich den schulen auch
eine größere verantwortung lassen also
nicht nur den regionen und der stadt und
der dorfschule sondern in diesem
konkreten fall eben der schule vom 3
also ich bin immer dafür auf die praxis
zu sein und wenn dir 100 leute vor ort
sagen wir haben ein problem dann ist es
höchst wahrscheinlich dass wir wirklich
eins haben ich war 16 jahre lang in der
lokalpolitik tätig ich plädiere sehr
dafür auch auf die praxis vor ort zu
hören und auch wirklich lösungen zu
finden die zu dem passen was vor ort
gebraucht wird deshalb können wir nicht
für alles ein bundesweites rezept
verordnen aber es ist eben auch hier aus
den beiträgen ja deutlich geworden dass
man nicht sozusagen zur normalität
zurückkommen kann wie ein schalter den
man um legt sondern das ist eine
schrittweise ein schrittweiser weg nur
möglich auch schon alleine aufgrund der
personellen situation und der abstands
und hygieneregeln wie ja nicht sofort
umsetzbar sind und der müssen flexible
pragmatische lösungen gefunden werden
auch vor ort mit den leuten mit den
kreativen ideen wie darum geht es jetzt
aber wir müssen den rahmen dafür
schaffen und das ermöglichen da sind die
spielplatz öffnung die geschehen können
seit heute eine gute entscheidung wenn
ich auch sehr froh drüber menschen das
wird auch viele familien entleert frau
gekämpft haben wir gleich herren schmidt
chanasit noch mal pause anfang keinen
gedanken noch zum schulwesen
der spiegel schrieb in seinem letzten
größeren bericht dazu dass unsere schule
vorerkrankungen hat wenn wir jetzt nach
der vollbremsung wieder langsam lockern
werden dann all die mängel unseres
schulsystems noch viel stärker zu tage
treten also ich weiß nicht ob das dann
passiert ich glaube es wird jetzt schon
deutlich dass eben schulen sehr
unterschiedlich auch agieren und das
eltern eben auch in sehr
unterschiedlichen konstellationen und
mit sehr unterschiedlichen
vielschichtigen umgangsweisen auch der
einzelnen schulen konfrontiert sind also
es gibt familien die wahnsinnig unter
druck stehen weil eben die schule
sozusagen einfach weitermacht ja
übrigens auch studenten ja wo die
hochschulen das eben entscheiden das
einfach exam weiter stattfinden
und ich meine im home office zu lernen
ich habe gar keine meinung zur die
abiturienten ja also der eine wird
vielleicht sagen ich habe es lieber
verschieben der andere würde vielleicht
sagen ich möchte die prüfung hinter mich
bringen
aber fakt ist ja es ist eine totale
ausnahme situation und es geht nicht nur
darum räume zu haben und dann wieder da
reingehen zu können eine
abstandsregelung zu halten sondern es
geht ja auch irgendwie darum prozess am
laufen zu halten
was mich noch mal beschäftigt da hab ich
würde gern auch eine frage stellen wenn
wir jetzt so schrittweise wieder
reingehen
dann müsste es ja eigentlich auch für
die situation jetzt sozusagen noch
einmal nachjustiert werden auch für die
familien das heißt eigentlich müsste es
doch mal
sie haben gesagt flexible lösungen vor
ort flexible lösungen auch in den
familien
weil wenn ich jetzt mit meinem
mutterherz mich da so rein spüre denke
ich abstandsregeln die erzieher müssen
abstand halten von den kindern die
kriegen irgendwie die masken das ist
keine gute situation für mein kind wenn
ich mein kind dahin gebe
das heißt ich würde gerne entscheiden
nehme ich diese betreuung in anspruch
für die zeit oder nicht und wenn ich die
nicht in anspruch nehme dann möchte ich
gerne in unterstützung haben ja so wie
eben auch unternehmen eine unterstützung
bekommen haben dass ich in irgendeiner
höhe das auch kompensieren kann in
irgendeiner finanziellen höhe und das
für mich dann entscheiden kann dann
vielleicht auch eine bezugsperson wieder
dazu nehme eine betreuung für mich
organisieren so dann ist das eine
interessante frage an den offensichtlich
wohl informiert christian lindner auch
in sachen nrw und schulen würden sie
denn sagen da ist wichtig auf eine
schulpflicht zu kochen oder ist es nicht
dann auch in der entscheidung der eltern
für ihre kinder zu sagen ob sie das
eigentlich für richtig halten oder ob
sie sagen wir haben da echt sorgen und
haben auch angst und möchten erst mal
einen bestimmten prozess noch abwarten
und maik behrens cooling bei der kita
ist es ja noch was anderes haben wir an
ist natürlich wenn wir über die schule
reden
die realität an die realität ist wir
reden über einen bruchteil der schüler
die zunächst einmal jetzt in die schule
zurückkehren wenn die klassen geteilt
werden dann ist beim raumprogramm schon
die hälfte der räume weg sagte eben
schon das je nach land je nach region
mindestens ein viertel der lehrkräfte
gar nicht zur verfügung stehen wir haben
vor erkrankungen können nicht alles ganz
leicht zu schließen ganz schwer auf zum
umso wichtiger jetzt möglichst rasch
planungssicherheit zu haben und zu
schauen
frau saalfrank spricht ja eine wichtige
frage an was machen wir mit denen die
kinder nicht in die kita geben können
oder wollen da gibt es ja ganz
unterschiedliche konstellationen eltern
die selber eine gesundheitliche
belastung haben und deshalb besonders
fürchten müssen dass die kinder was nach
hause jetzt aber auch sehr
unterschiedlich daneben der punkt was
kann man da machen ich bin schon seit
langer zeit der auffassung dass wir die
steuerlichen möglichkeiten um
kinderbetreuungskosten auch geltend zu
machen beim finanzamt dass wir das
erhöhen müssen das ist heute eine
größenordnung die ist zehn jahre als
zehn jahre nicht angefasst worden ist
wenn eine direkte hilfe für familien die
sagen so ich will kinder betreuen neben
dem beruf das wäre eine der
möglichkeiten und ich glaube wir sind
sofort hier aller meiner meinung dass
wir bei dem ganzen bereich homeschooling
digitalisierung viel besser werden
können also vom faxgerät dass in den
gesundheitsämtern noch genutzt wird bis
zu den digitalen möglichkeiten in der
schule haben wir viele defizite an denen
wird der länder weisen wie viel
direktere hilfe wäre wenn man mal
endlich überall wohl noch in den ländern
nrw gehört dazu dreistellige beträge im
monat eine kita gebühren aufgerufen
werden wenn man da mal sagen würde
während lassen die eltern hier nicht nur
für drei monate vor sondern wir gehen da
wirklich mal konsequent runter da
könnten die familien home kind mit
mehreren hundert euro haben gefragt ich
habe eine gute nachricht für sie ja nach
dem regierungswechsel von rot grün zu
schwarzgeld haben geld haben wir ein
weiteres kindergartenjahr beitragsfrei
und was ist mit den andern sind eine
länder für reiter ja ok gegeben
wir haben es geht wir haben eine chance
haben
es geht ja nicht nur darum jetzt sie sei
eine entlastung stattfindet nicht
ausschließen aber es geht nicht nur
darum dann etwas nicht sozusagen auf zu
bringen sondern es geht auch etwas darum
die leistung zu würdigen weil das was
dort passiert ist ja auch sozusagen
beziehungsarbeit ja kinder zu hause zu
betreuen das ist ja nochmal was anderes
als sozusagen dann beitragsfrei die
kinder in die kita zu geben wie wohl
wenn man parallel dazu arbeiten will das
ist wirklich echt schwer ist und es
deshalb total gut wäre wenn die kinder
eben endlich wieder im wahrsten sinne
des wortes betreut werden mit fantasie
wir müssen einmal noch auf die kleineren
schauen kita gibt es ein vier stufen
programm das haben sie verfolgt frau
gefallen könnte es uns erklären die
spielplätze sind jetzt wieder geöffnet
auch unter denen hygienemaßnahmen und
richtlinien ist das zu gefährlich
einfach weil man ich glaube in einem
vier oder fünf jahren keine
hygieneregeln beibringen kann
das liegt ja auf der hand und ich glaube
da muss ich auch nochmal einbinden
entgegnen der mich ja ins konklave
schicken wir mit christian drosten dass
wir nicht glauben sondern wir wissen
dass wir eben sehr wenig wissen weil das
neue virus und insofern trifft das genau
diesem punkt christian sieht sozusagen
jeden tag aufs neue publikationen und
teilt das einfach mit und diese
publikationen sind gerade in diesem
bereich was die infektiosität von
kindern betrifft nun mal unterschiedlich
und das hat er einfach nur kommuniziert
und damit muss man dann eben als politik
auch umgehen so ist einfach die
situation
wir müssen jetzt leider sagen wir wissen
eben nach wie vor nicht geht von kindern
eine sozusagen infektionsgefahr raus das
betrifft er dann auch sozusagen
letztendlich die spielplätze
was wir wissen ist das sicherlich
schmierinfektion keine große rolle
spielen werden
und wenn es einen flächen richtig genau
sondern eben natürlich die tröpfchen die
fliegen und wenn man da eben darauf
achten kann dass die kinder mit ihren
freunden zusammenspielen und nicht mit
unbekannten kindern und dass die eltern
auch als auseinander stehen sozusagen um
da nicht neue infektionsketten zu
schaffen die vor allem nicht
nachvollziehbar sind dass es einmal das
große problem auf öffentlichen
spielplätzen dass sie da eben dann zum
teil ja auch eben nicht bekannte leute
treffen also wenn das eben verhindert
werden kann dann ist da schon mal auch
viel gemacht denn wenn wir über zu reden
und paar
und grünanlagen entweder hier bundesliga
ist ja ich finde ist sieht man kann
nicht in einem atemzug über die
bundesliga reden und die anlage auf der
anderen seite die kinder nicht wieder
auf die schaukel zurücklassen das
insofern unterschiedlich das ist ganz
unterschiedlich und trotzdem sage ich
ihnen aus kindersicht ist das schon ein
wichtiger punkt und ich finde es deshalb
gut dass heute diese entscheidung
getroffen wurde
da es eben familien auch wieder mehr
bewegungsmöglichkeiten im freien
bekommen gerade in den stadtgebieten in
den ballungsräumen wo sowieso schon
wenig räume für kinder da sind um sich
im grünen und in meppen freien zu
bewegen ist das eine ganz wichtige
endlich schnell hat er dann auch den
vierjährigen irgendwie an und um abend
sich und da hat ihn irgendwie wieder in
engster körperlicher nähe und wie will
man das verhindern oder will es
irgendwie gerade dann auch untersagen
das sind ja ich glaube wir müssen trotz
alledem auch 1 irgendwie mal aussehen
das leben und alles was sich damit
verbindet hat auch gefahren die uns
allen immer begegnen und trotzdem
brauchen wir auch einmal das leben ist
lebensgefährlich sagt man sagen aber man
kann sich man muss abwägen wie viel man
sich schützen kann und wie viel freiheit
man dafür aufgeben müssen und das ist
etwas was auch gerade im sinne der
kinder eine ganz wichtige frage ist und
außerdem glaube ich dass auch ein
bisschen erlebtes ich habe eben selber
mutter man kann mit ferienkindern
wunderbar händewaschen lernen und üben
und man kann den auch erklären was ein
virus ist und was der macht und das
natürlich kindgerecht aber dass man
einfach den kindern abspricht zu
verstehen was hier gerade passiert ich
glaube es ist nicht in ordnung und ich
glaube dass kinder gerade viel viel mehr
verstehen als wir manchmal in hessen
sich dennoch an ihrer kinder sind ja
auch und das ist das wunderbare auch
sehr impulsiv messias wir mit dem
vernunft regel nämlich die gehen in
verbindung wir haben es gehört von der
schule das natürlich auch die
jugendlichen rudelbildung haben dabei
die nachricht lust haben
deswegen und das kann man nicht so
leicht abfinden und das sollte man auch
glaube ich nicht ist man kann es nicht
und es ist auch eben auch da wieder in
abwägung es ist auch für die entwicklung
der kinder wichtig kinder brauchen
kinder
man lässt es einfach auch zu sehen bei
all der diskussionen bei all den
schritten die jetzt weiter gegangen und
ein vollständig risikoloses leben ist
kein schönes leben
am 65 haben wir dann endlich ein clown
so habe ich jetzt schon
der stufenplan ist ja formuliert worden
von den fachministern eine andere idee
war am ende steht die entscheidung der
ministerpräsidenten über konkrete
zeitpunkte um heute ist vereinbart
worden dass die am 6
mai dann auch getroffen werden dann
machen wir einen punkt ich darf mich
ganz herzlich bedanken bei ihnen und
gebe weiter an markus lanz der heute
unter anderem reiner haselhoff zu gast
hat den ministerpräsidenten von sachsen
anhalt und alexander graf lambsdorff und
wir sehen uns wenn sie mögen am
kommenden donnerstag wieder um 22 uhr 15
passen sie gut auf sich auf ganz
herzlichen dank
[Musik]